Speaker 1: Mypillow on the verge of failing is now
trying to advertise on the David Pakman show. Can
you believe this? This is a nice little story.
So as a reminder, we talked a few days ago about
how Mypillow, according to Mike Lindell, has
supposedly suffered a decline of $100 million
in revenue thanks to a massive cancellation is
what Pillow is calling it. Pillow said that the
box stores think it means big box stores. The
box stores sounds almost like stores that sell
boxes. The box stores canceled him. And so now
he is auctioning off equipment and this includes
box trucks and sprinter vans and all sorts of
different equipment. Recently, MSNBC had an
unintentionally funny segment about this.
Speaker 3: For the low, low price of five
American dollars, this thing could be
yours. It is an industrial pillow roller.
It rolls pillows. Right. But it's not just
any industrial pillow roller. It's a my
pillow pillow roller from the my pillow pillow
factory. My pillow is auctioning off more than
850 pieces of equipment from sewing machines to
forklifts. The company is even subletting part
of its manufacturing space.
Speaker 2: Right.
Speaker 3: Why? Because my pillow
is not everyone's pillow or even a
lot of people's pillow.
Speaker 1: All right,
you get the point. We covered this. So all of this
is going on. And yesterday I go to my computer
and we work with a lot of agencies that will bring
us advertisers. And I get the following message.
Potential advertiser. You have received an
invite to a campaign for my pillow for the show,
the David Pakman show, YouTube. My pillow is
potentially interested in advertising on your
show. Would you accept an order from them if it
came through? And then it links to my pillow e-com
and I can tell them with a single click yes,
count me in or no, I will pass. Now, in a moment,
I'll tell you what I did. I posted about this to
my Twitter, into my threads, into my Instagram.
I was stunned at the number of people who, first
of all, thought we might actually advertise
Mypillow. We've had Mike Lindell on. I think
he's just horrible in every way. I, of course,
would not advertise Mypillow We advertise other
pillows. We're not doing it. Okay. There were a
bunch of people who wrote back to me mostly on
Twitter, who said, David, it's a great brand.
You should really do it. That's really an honor.
And I was like, These people have to be joking.
I looked. They were not joking. They were very
serious. So that was really weird. The second
thing is, I heard. Many people in our audience who
said, David, you're not really going to do this,
are you? I will cancel my subscription if
you advertise Mypillow folks. Everybody can
relax. We are not advertising Mypillow We're not
advertising. Mypillow And I'm going to be super
honest with you. I believe that what happened here
is not that Mypillow is desperate to specifically
advertise on the David Pakman Show. I think as
a sort of last ditch to try new things, Mypillow
hired a new ad agency, one of the ones we work
with and said, Get us on tons of shows we've never
advertised on before. We've got to do something
to stem the bleeding. And so this was probably
sent out to dozens, if not hundreds of shows.
If Mike you know, Mike Lindell knows me. If he
doesn't if he hasn't forgotten that he knows me.
He can contact us directly and just say, Hey, do
you want to advertise Mypillow? It would not come
through an advertiser, I think, if it was actually
them saying, We really want the David Packman
show. So everybody relax. We're not going to be
advertising the pillows. We're not advertising
mypillow. But a very, very interesting moment.